mr sharma really good to see you this
morning and of course as always
lots to talk about on your brief but but
i hope you'll forgive me for
for starting with schools as as titan
does rather seem to be of the essence
in getting our children back into
education is there no way in which
we can see a certain set of
circumstances in which masks
face coverings of some kind might well
make their way into secondary schools in
england in the way that we are seeing at
north of the border
but only look i mean firstly i think
it's really vital that we get
all school children back in september
and when it comes to face coverings we
have
followed the scientific advice and
medical advice that we've been getting
and we've made it very clear that in
certain settings such as transport or
in in shops it is mandatory but public
health england has provided with advice
which has been consistent throughout and
of course schools have been open
uh throughout this pandemic period
serving uh taking care of
vulnerable children the children of of
key workers and i want to thank
all the teachers who works incredibly
hard to support them but
public health england to be very clear
which is that they do not recommend
the wearing of face masks in schools and
the reason for this is because
uh children uh pupils are obviously uh
mixing
in uh the same cohorts uh we've also
provided through public health england
uh guidance in terms of how schools can
keep
uh children safe how they can keep
teachers safe and how
schools can be secure covert secure
environment so uh
there is no uh current plan to review
that particular guidance
sure the the reason according to nicola
sturgeon that she's considering it
in scotland is because in her view you
know mixing in corridors and communal
areas
might well make the likelihoods of
transmission
increase i wonder are there any
circumstances under which the government
would simply say look
if you want to wear a mask be your
teacher
or a student then you can do so leave
the decision up to them
well look i think you have to look also
at the the the
the science of this and um you would
have seen the
uh messaging that's come from the chief
medical officers in the deputy chief
medical officers
are saying very clearly that the chances
of being
uh infected from government in the
school is very very small
and i mean if you look at the statistics
from public health england
in in june we had on average around a
million children
in uh preschool and primary settings
and there were 70 uh incidents of
infection so
the chances of being infected in school
are incredibly low in fact
uh it is the chance of of being infected
or higher outside a school setting
so we have to go on the basis of the
scientific and medical advice that we
get
and that is very clear at this stage uh
which is that uh there is not
a recommendation for wearing face
coverings in schools
yeah indeed but despite those statistics
which i'm sure
which many people will be aware of there
still remains lingering concerning the
part of some parents about
about putting their children back in i
just wonder one last question on this if
i can
it has there been guidance issued to
local authorities so that there is some
standard procedure across the country
when it comes to the possibility of
schools being closed be because we've
seen a localized spiker
or whatever reason i'm just wondering if
there is a standardised approach
a bar beyond which a school a local
authority will know that a school
needs to be closed well i mean we we
take this on as
a case-by-case basis and you've seen
across the country there have been uh
local lockdowns
uh as uh infection rates have gone down
uh certain bits of lockdown have been uh
removed
uh i think the one thing they were very
clear about is that uh of course we want
to keep
schools open uh and uh if uh
we were to be in a lockdown situation
local area i think the the last
thing we would want to do is to shut
schools down it's really important
neil and i you know your viewers will
understand this and you understand this
for the life chances of our children we
need to make sure that they're back in
school
uh they're getting that support it's
good for their health being it's good
for their education it's good for their
future